[Music]
i used to think it was not true that all
spiritual work began with one's self
you know i felt like that was a way of
disempowering people and saying you know
if you wait until you're an avatar
you'll never join the people rioting in
the street
and i used to say you know if you see
people rioting you have a moral
obligation to join
you don't even have to know what it's
about
uh the people rioting is a sufficient
imperative to political action to be
there well
i'm not 25 anymore
that provided a lot of fun
but i now think
you know you do not make
a uh
unflawed contribution unless you first
gotten your ducks somewhat in order i'm
not saying you have to be able to walk
on water but you have to have at least
considered your own life and your values
and that sort of thing
you know
it's pretty simple the ethical life
it's just demanding
many of you have heard me say this this
is this is my uh
this is father mccann talking
the moral life
does not consist of wheatgrass diet
or affirmations
or anything the moral life is
you should clothe the naked
you should feed the hungry
comfortably afflicted
bury the dead
and there are a couple others
obvious things to be done
i have never seen
a a truly superior person i don't
believe and if i have they were so
humble and self-effacing that they never
would have claimed that superiority is
their own
the mushroom said to me once and i've
said it to many of you many times
it said for one human being to seek
enlightenment from another is like a
grain of sand on the beach
seeking enlightenment from another
don't you get it it's the same flesh
it's the same flesh nobody knows
anything you don't know and even if they
do it's not your knowledge so what good
is it doing you
the idea that it's okay for you not to
understand mathematics or not to play
the violin because somebody else does it
very well
is a complete compound you will be held
responsible for what you know
and what you can do
it's fun
to take responsibility
it's fun
to test the water
it's the hardest thing to put across to
oneself and to other people is that the
universe is a more friendly place than
we have been told
the culture is institutionalized
paranoia
and it's very hard to decondition
oneself from this no matter how
deconditioned you may think you are
there is
more and more work to be done and i
think the essence of taoism and why its
roots in nature are so powerful is
because what taoism is saying is if you
will quiet
your mind
and if you will pay attention
you will discover that you are
supported and cared for
by the dynamic of the universe
this should be obvious by virtue of the
fact that you're even alive
i mean how unlikely is your existence
i put it to you pretty unlikely and yes
here you are
well do you just think it was the
greatest series of well-rolled dice in
history
that's silly
that's ridiculous
probability would never have delivered
us
to this room this afternoon
probability sculpted by loving intent
has
delivered us to this room
once you can sense that living
intent
and
make it an object of
familiarity
that is the antidote to cultural
paranoia and to the acceptance of your
identity through imposed definitions
by other people
you know it really is true as the bible
says you must become as a little child
and
that means you must become
pre-cultural
you must recover who you were
before the engines of culture went to
work on you and abused you and made you
afraid and dumbed you down distorted
your values and so forth and so on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you